hello everyone I hope your Friday was
excellent and it still is and if that
the case why not make it even better
with a very interesting game from round
six of the 2018 candidates tournament
here we have Wesley so with the white
pieces against eleven Oregon and it's a
it's a really home preparation against
home preparation but later is it simply
explodes and it's interesting the eleven
aragón employs one of his favorite
defenses and it's interesting to see how
Wesley prepared for it now thanks to
Nikki we have some fresh photos from
this tournament here we have eleven on
the right and Wesley on the left and
immediately when I saw this photo I
noticed that Wesley has his coffee mug
with a plate coffee
little coffee plate under it and eleven
only has a coffee mug which could mean
that eleven takes his coffee black and
Wesley takes it with sugar as he does
have a little spoon and on that plate so
just a little thing I spotted could be
could be anything else but just putting
it out there so let's see this game so
Wesley has the white pieces and he opens
it with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 Dora Lopez
and everyone wants to make F I mean of
course everyone wants to win their game
but you at least one draw the game you
don't want to lose the game as tomorrow
is the rest day so you don't want to
have an entire rest day feeling like we
lost yesterday we have a 6 more fees
defense brush up to a 492 f6 we have
castles the blush up to e7 rook to e1
all standard b5 Bishop to b3 we have
castles by Aragon and now a4 b4 and now
a5 and well this a five does seem like a
like weird move maybe it will get a bit
risky maybe black can go Ruby eight rook
b5 and wind upon you'll see that Wesley
has all of this well figured out so d6
we have d3 Bishop to e6 now the
immediate exchange Bishop captures F
captures and Knight B to d2
rook to b8 and now Knight to b3
to be three it doesn't seem like it has
any bright future there but it does
protect from the media to rock to be
five followed by capturing the a five
porn and also after white performs this
C 3 and D for the night will nicely
support the push of the pawn on d4 Queen
to c8 we have h3 night to d8 and Bishop
to e3 now c5 as you don't want to allow
this Bishop and any chances of ever
getting to b6 that would be very nice
for white so c5 we have a knight B to d2
and now Knight to c6 we have a c3 and
now rook the b5 and here are a nun wants
to win this a five-point Wesley pushes
d4 we have it capture some d4c captures
on d4 and now Knight captures on a 5d
captures on c5 d captures on c5 and now
rook to a2 and I believe this was all in
Wesley's home preparation as this rook
to a2 is is definitely the the engine's
choice here the idea being that if if
for example after this rope to a to for
example c4 then you could go Queen to a1
simply making room for the Queen on a1
and after Queen to a1 attacking this
knight on e5 Knight to b3 Knight
captures pawn captures rook captures
black is now up up but isn't really up
upon its it's an equal material but
black has these BB pawns and a weak ecig
spawn so this would be definitely an
advantageous for white for example
Knight captures okay now you do grab a
pawn but after Bishop to d4 now opening
up an attack on the night from the rook
Night Moves captures captures and now
rook captures and e6 and now the
material is again equal but with a
better position for white so this worked
way to move definitely an interesting
home recipe Queen to be 7 by 11 now
attacking this eforp on twice we have B
3 and now King to h8
it's you you could grab this pawn
immediately with night captures night
captures Queen captures but then Bishop
captures on c5 simply opening up an
attack on on blacks Queen Queen has to
move and then White has a variety of
options but black doesn't really achieve
anything here so after b3 King to h8 and
now Queen to c2 now guarding that efore
pawn Knight to d7 rook to a1 now
attacking the knight and a5 Bishop to d8
defending it and now Knight to c4 Knight
captures Queen captures and now Bishop
to f6 as Wesley is attacking this e 6
pawn but for now Aragon is attacking the
rook on a1 so rook to d1 and now Queen
to c6 defending d6 pawn rook a to d2 now
doubling up on the D file again
attacking the knight and D seven Knights
to b6 attacking the Queen and now Queen
to c2 Queen to c7
and now comes C 5 and e5 is a very
dangerous move it seems like you're
offering a pawn here as both Bishop and
Queen are attacking it but what you're
actually doing is opening up the Queen's
diagonal all the way to h7 and now if
you capture white simply plays Knight g5
and it's game over you have to guard
against checkmate on h7 I have to put g6
Knight captures on e6 you'll lose the
exchange and the game so after E 5
Bishop to e7 we have night to d4 of
course the knight can be captured the
Queen on c7 is undefended rook to DA I
roped the c8 defending the Queen and now
Knight captures on e6 Queen captures on
e5 and this is one of the reasons why
this could have been Wesley's candidates
immortal or anything however we want to
call it here what's the plate Knight to
f4 but there was an extremely
interesting line with rook to d6 whoever
would have found Brooke to d6 is like
really amazing point being that now
you're you're preventing
see for the immediate as there would be
some threats against the knight nb6 from
the rook against the bishop another
thing you're protecting the night on e 6
and of course
the thing everyone wants to know what
happens after Bishop captures on d6 well
then comes Knight to g5 with the
terrible threat of Queen to h7 checkmate
and another terrible threat if that is
defended in night to f7 check picking up
the Queen on e5 so g6 isn't an option
because it was the Queen
so here black would have to do some
serious maneuvering to simply at least
try and get out of trouble with Queen to
h2 check King F 1 and now g6 so now
there's no night to f7 winning the Queen
but now simply rook captures on b6 and
here black is again in a lot of trouble
he doesn't have anything to do Queen to
be to check is a terrible threat black
can't stop this black can play Queen e5
simply night to f7 again picks up the
Queen you can't grab the rope can be 6
because Queen to f7 again picks up the
knight to f7 again picks up the Queen so
you would have to remain over the Queen
with Queen to h1 King e2 and now Queen
to a1 the guard this dark square
diagonal but now Queen to d2 is deadly
threatening a rock to d8 after you stop
this then comes Knight f7 check King G
King g7 Bishop h6 check King captures
night and now the king is in the mating
net there are a couple of more lines
that could have happened but you know
all of them lead to a win for white but
okay rook to d6 not an easy move to find
definitely a voiceless one preparation
didn't stretch this far into the game he
played Knight to f4 also a nice move
Roop to f8 and attacking the knight of
course threatening rook captures night
and now rook to e2 and here Quintus III
was played and Quintus III wasn't wasn't
the best move by Aragon as Queen to a to
going for this a6 pawn refutes that
immediately but obviously had a
different idea
he played Queen to be one Aragon
retreated Queen to f6 and now Bishop to
see one now Wesley's idea is I'm gonna
bring the bishop here to be - - I this
g7 pawn and here you have to you have to
be very careful what you do
best idea would be to move the Queen to
f7 play rock to c8 and then prepare C
for re undecided to play C for
immediately and if it was just a
decision he wasn't in time trouble or
anything
the idea being of course that if Bishop
to b2 he'll just block it with c3 but
Wesley captured on c4 we have Knight
captures on c4 and now rook to e6 and
here you're you're you know you're in a
lot of trouble what you could do here is
well you have to move the Queen obvious
the best best thing to do was would be
to play Queen to f7
but these dis leads to a forced
variation which would be basically lost
for black after rook to d7 simply with a
double attack on the Bishop rook the
fence and up Queen to b4 and there is no
way to add more defense to the bishop on
e7 you can move the bishop otherwise you
lose the Queen
so like black would have the option of
going something like rookie 5 rook
captures Knight captures Queen captures
Bishop to f6 rook captures Bishop
captures and after Knight to d3 black
would have these two connected passed
pawns on the Queen side but it's not
enough to hold against an extra piece
so after this rook to e6 move our onion
had a different idea if he wanted he
wanted to try something as he didn't
think he could hold that position and he
played Queen to g5 and here again you
could you could try a lot of things you
could improve your position first rook
to d7 is again an idea but Wesley is
greedy and he wants to grab the Queen
immediately he plays Knight to g6 check
this check the King force the rook
that's less important as the Queen is
also attacked on g5 so this was our
onions idea Queen captures on g6 rook
captures hCAP force on g6 and now Queen
to e4 it I mean I haven't seen the
interview or anything I don't think he
actually missed a move like Queen to b4
because this loses a piece now the
bishop on e7 is attacked and the knight
and c4 maybe he thought that even even
this was okay so Bishop to f6 and now
Queen captures on c4 and now b3 so now
he does have a nicely played
but repin f6 that will be supporting the
spawn after it reaches b2 and he does
have two ropes so he maybe he could have
some chances here I mean should the
chances are better than holding that
position we've seen so Bishop 283
attacking the rook on f8 rook now
doubles on the B file and now rook to be
one
arjan pushes b2 and now we have h4 rook
25 we have Queen to d3 rock to rock - a
rock to d8 attacking the Queen Queen
moves the b3 rook to c8 rook to Queen -
b7 now attacking the rook on c8r up to
d8 and now Queen back to d3 here wersal
was still trying to figure out how to go
about this position look back to see
eight and now Wesley finds that he plays
Queen to b4 attacking the rook on a5 we
have rook to be 5 and here the precise
idea is Queen to a for picking up the a6
pawn but Wesley goes for a different
idea Queen to g4 now attacking the rook
on c8 we have roped the c3 attacking the
bishop
that's why Queen to a4 was more precise
it doesn't allow this rook to see to
remove and but okay this was Wesley's
idea which is again winning rush of
capture some b2 rook captures rook
captures rook to C 1 check King h2 and
now Bishop captures on b2 so now Aragon
has a rook a bishop and a nice passed a
sex pawn but the pawn majority and the
King side is definitely decisive and of
course our neo knows this is a lost
position but no one wants to lose the
game in the candidate tomorrow with the
rest day so they kind of played this
position on for for quite a quite a long
time and there was an interesting
discussion is it disrespectful maybe
maybe continuing this position but
everyone agreed that it wasn't you know
if you were playing you would you would
try something you would still have
chances may be white blunders but you
know they did say that Wesley was
definitely enjoying crushing Aragon and
maybe even Wesley wanted this game to go
on for as long as possible but ok Queen
captures on g6
rock to a 1 and now you have a problem
here
there is no there is no castle or
fortress black could make you can't have
your Bishop rook and pawn guarded at all
times because the king is simply to bear
and the checks from the Queen will be
decisive so G for hereby Wesley now a5
Queen to h5 check King to g8 and now
Queen to b5 and this was an interesting
position again we are forcing when is
Queen to EA to check
now with the idea that King to h7 leads
the Queen to e2 now attacking the bishop
forcing it to move
if you guard with the rook then simply
Queen to c2 check picks up the rook
brush up moves now Queen the d3 check
King to g8 and now Queen to d4 now
forcing the rook to move again you can't
move to a to simply Queen to c4 check
picks it up rook to e1 but now Queen to
d5 check King to h8 Queen to d8 check
King to h7 Queen to d3 check and now
King has to go to g8 and now you simply
grab that Bishop on a3 so this was the
idea you can't have all of your pieces
protected at all times because there are
simply too many checks but what's the
one for a different idea he played Queen
to b5 attacking the bishop bishop to a3
Queen to e5 now forcing the rope to move
rook to d1 but now you have a problem if
you play Queen to e3 attacking the
bishop the rook will simply move to a1
and protect the bishop and if you play
Queen to c3 to attack the bishop then
Bishop to d6 comes with two check and
again like black Google's out but again
Quintus III was was the way to go but
okay Quinta e6 check first Wesley wants
to pick up the a pawn and then he will
slowly slowly slowly build up his
position King to h7 queenie for check
King to h8 now Queen to aah checking h7
and picking up the pawn so now black
really doesn't have any counter play
Bishop to d6
this comes with check King G to rock to
d4
Queen to f5 check King moves and now
Queen to h5 checking g8 and now g5 here
came to f8 Queen to g6 Bishop to e7
Queen to F
five we have King te 8 and now King to
h3 are preparing to push f4 and bring
the King even closer Rock to d6 we have
Queen to h7 going for that pawn king
defends at f4 is coming rock attack
spawn Queen check
he moves to e8 Queen to e5 now attacking
the rook rock moves and now we have King
to G for protecting the f4 pawn King to
g8 King to f8 defending the gee-pole now
Queen to f5 check King moves Queen to e6
rock to rock to d4 and now Queen to e5
and it was in this position that 11
iranian finally resigned the game as now
after the rock moves wesley will pick up
the g7 pawn and then there's really
nothing to think about anymore so yeah a
very interesting game I do hope you
enjoyed it I'm sure our onion didn't as
Wesley crushed him in in his favorite
variation so that's that's why I mean at
this level home preparation is basically
basically everything and other than that
c4 push our onion they don't really make
any any big mistakes but you know and
yeah it's a shame Wesley didn't see that
rook to d6 move that would have made a
significant game you know one for one
for the books but you know it's it's
better just to win the game after all
these are the candidates so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
once again I would like to thank Nikki
for sending us always some fresh photos
all of the links to our social media
will be in the description below so feel
free to follow her if you're into chest
photography as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I would like to
thank Janos better for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and I will I will probably
show one more game tomorrow morning from
the candidates probably Kramnik versus
mamedyarov and i will include the
standings in tournament so far before
the rest day so yeah thank you once
again and I will see you soon